let's head back to London where Kevin
has the latest on the Royals after Queen
Elizabeth II's historic funeral where do
they go from here Kev well Michelle
hopefully there will be a lot of healing
especially when it comes to Brothers
William and Harry you know all the
sources that we have talked to say the
royal family is ready to embrace Harry
once again the big problem is trust but
let's start first with King Charles III
who is a man on the move
that's Charles in Scotland today barely
12 hours after saying his final goodbye
to his mother a source says the King has
returned to Balmoral for private time
the family including William and Kate
who attach these handwritten notes to
the Queen's coffin will now observe
seven days of mourning all public
engagements are canceled until next
Tuesday as for Harry and Megan we've
learned they're heading back to
California so they can see Archie and
Lil bet but there is a report that Megan
reached out to Charles wrote him a note
asking for a private conversation
Charles is very very keen to try on
smooth relations and given that they
were over here for well over a week
there would have been time for both of
them to speak with Charles
yesterday Harry puffed out his cheeks
with a dramatic exhale leaving the
services he did have this sweet moment
grinning at knee Charlotte who was like
a buffer for the feuding Brothers Royal
authors Tina Brown and Andrew Morton
weigh in on what's next do they want
Harry and Megan back here I really
believe that they feel they need them
actually but whether they have the trust
is something else they're so afraid
about Harry's book that he is writing
unless that one stops they're not going
to be able to heal they fear that
anything they say will wind up in a book
or they'll wind up in a podcast so that
has to happen before that reconciliation
happens and I think if he did that I
think they would like him back there's a
lot of work to do what would Diana make
of her boys and their relationship now
well the one thing that she would be
really infuriated about would be the
fact that they've split and because she
always said to me Harry is Williams
backup he's his wingman he's the one who
helps William in this difficult job that
he will have in the future because it's
a lonely job they were best friends it
did upset me that's Charles's former
Butler Grant Harold he addressed the
report that claims the King has been on
a power trip with his staff demanding
things like ironing his shoelaces and
putting toothpaste on his toothbrush
I've never heard of this I worked for
the man why would he even iron shoelaces
it doesn't even make sense Grant also
got emotional recalling how the queen
fulfilled his own childhood dream in the
ballroom
I got to dance with her exactly as that
dream when I was a kid
when she died her body was beating them
all up in that place where you got to
dance with her I put a message up on
social media and I just said I said
Thank you again a 14 year old
boy a chance to dance with you you know
it meant something to me